I understand Pete dr. Jill ramped and I
were sitting around talking and Disney
was in its second heyday they were doing
unbelievable films you know in that era
of the Little Mermaid Beauty and the
Beast Aladdin Lion King right in that
era and we made a list actually of what
we didn't want our film to be and we
didn't want to be musical we didn't want
it to be you know a villain that wants
to take over the world we didn't want it
to be you know the the the main
character being kind of boring and all
the characters around him would be
interesting the comic sidekicks and the
bad guys and so on we wanted the main
character to be the most interesting
character in the film and we wanted to
feel more contemporary in storytelling
and so so we started looking around and
we discovered we discovered the buddy
picture as as a genre of storytelling
that no one had done in animation before
and we fell in love with it because
there are so many great buddy pictures
in but the buddy picture by nature we
loved because the main character the two
main characters change dramatically
through through the film and that's what
we wanted because we felt we felt that
the the emotion of the character was
going to come from it always comes from
the protagonists the main character
changing and growing and in learning
something and so we started developing
this ventriloquist dummy kind of Charlie
McCarthy like ventriloquist dummy and
and the tinny as the the tin toy and we
were going and I just was looking at my
own family at that point we Nancy and I
have five sons and as they were growing
up I would recognize that they wouldn't
play with a tin toy as as a new toy
because we felt like a buddy picture
with toys would be a new child's
favorite toy an old toy is replaced by a
new toy and was a ventriloquist dummy
was a favorite toy and they get replaced
by the the replaced by the the little
tin toy and it just didn't feel right
and I kept looking at my my son's what
they were played with and they were
playing with action
figures and I started thinking well it
should be an action figure
because that's really what what is is
what kids are playing with and then I I
just remembered back to two seminal
things in my life one I grew up during
the 60s when when the space race was
going on and and the astronauts were
going to the moon and they were the
coolest guys on the planet when they
walked out my parents would get me up
and we'd watch them live on TV walking
out to get in that elevator to go up and
climb into that capsule to go to the
moon and these guys were walking in the
white suits with the clear helmets and
they had the kind of little skull caps
on with it with you know the the ear you
know the the microphones and the
headphones on and so and you sit there
and they were so cool and I thought oh
my god that's great so I never forgot
that and also Star Wars which was such
an important film for all of us really
but it but it was so so so important you
know in in kind of space becoming sir
vibrant storytelling again and and so so
I thought well it should be a space
superhero a you know kind of space
action figure kind of superhero guy and
that's where the evolution from from the
tin toy went and then it was bud lucky
who was one of the great story guys that
that worked with us who was older than
us who's from Montana and he said well
have you thought about the ventriloquist
dummy being a cowboy and right away I
knew that was perfect because in Buddy
pictures you have to make the the the
the two characters in the beginning of
the film as opposite as possible you
know the one that was really important
to us was the Defiant ones starring
Sidney Poitier and Tony Curtis you know
and and it's in a prison in the south
where you know a black man from the
north is handcuffed to to erases from
from the south and they get into it
they're being transferred they get it to
an exit and they escape the white guy
wants to go south the black guy wants to
go north you can't get more opposite
than that and it's the most powerful
film it's not a comedy it's a drama but
you just to see these two grow together
and they're literally handcuffed to
gather and it's so powerful and that's
what's so inspiring for us with this and
so that really became the foundation of
the story that we started to tell so we
get we start developing the story and
everyone at Disney was really concerned
that that that adults teenagers college
students they would why would they come
to a movie to see toys being played with
by a kid and having the word toy in the
title it's like no one's gonna see this
is too juvenile you got to make it edgy
or you got to make it edgy or you got to
make it you know they kept saying edgy
and you got to make it edgy you know and
so we're okay you know clearly they know
you know we're never done a feature and
we're drawing away and trying to make it
and so he kept pushing the you know
woody woody the main character the the
character Tom Hanks was going to play to
be to be edgy and edgy and edgy and then
we we finally put together like the
first act of the film and we showed it
to Disney with all this you know notes
that they were given that we had to do
mandatory notes and and so this is an
image kind of during that time and woody
was not likable at all and we were we we
we thought okay this is we gate we did
their notes and we showed it to him and
it was a disaster
it was horrible we call it Black Friday
and and it was it was really horrible
they they said what happened this is
like kind of unlikable unwatchable oh my
god and and and they were they were
threatening they wanted to shut the
production down I also got a call from
Peter Schneider maybe sitting in my car
telling him that we had to move Pixar
down to Burbank to finish the film they
thought you clearly can't do it yourself
we're gonna move you down and you're
gonna be right next to us while we
develop the story with you because you
clearly can't do it on your own and we
kind of looked at each other and it was
oh my god and this was like three weeks
before Christmas and I just couldn't
imagine like taking all my all my guys
and gals away from their families right
before Christmas to go down there and
sit with him and so we we we you know I
basically went to Peter Schneider and
went to them and said please give us two
weeks give us two weeks and let us let
us turn things around we taught it we
convinced them to give us two weeks and
so we went back and we looked at each
other and we said let's tell the story
we want to tell and we from that point
on it was a found a fundamental shift in
the way we we even still to this day we
deal with kind of notes and stuff is
that we use the notes that we that we
think are going to make the movie better
and we we ignore the notes that we we
don't think it's gonna make the movie
better we kind of just sort of quietly
ignored the whole mandatory note concept
and we just sat there and spent two
weeks and one of the things that was
unique is that because the Lucasfilm
computer division invented nonlin
digital nonlinear film editing with the
Edit droid we were the first animated
film to be using the avid was brand new
and we grabbed hold of that thing and I
said this is the way and Disney kept
saying no we only we only see things on
film and we said okay fine but we're
gonna use the avid you know and and then
we'll transfer it onto a film which we
did we had to do that and so so but but
we were able to to work day and night
and we rewrote the whole beginning of
the film from from the very beginning of
film until buzz lightyear rise and flies
around the room